2 tutti ti saresti serenità e oggi nuova
challenge che non abbiamo mai fatto
prima volta le fantastiche challenge
ingredienti slime bowling pratichiamo da
tiger comunque randi quali giochini
abbiamo visto questo mini bulli cui con
noi andremo a tirare la pallina che
vedete qua e in base a quanti birilli
facciamo cadere prenderemo l'ingrediente
slime corrispondente ovviamente se
facciamo cadere pochi birilli ad esempio
uno due o tre gli ingredienti sono un po
più brutti rimane tempo il verde che ci
quale più sporchi o di abitare e voi
avete dovremo essere bravi a buttare più
virili possibile è prendere appunto gli
ingredienti tv come sempre vincerà chi
ha lo slime più bello è che fa so niente
mr ma tu sei proprio grembo l'ing
e così così e bracciano io sono
prontissimo
vedremo come un po più diverso perché
ovviamente è il miniatura poi alla fine
del video potrete votare come sempre in
un sondaggio che vi lasciano qua se ho
vinto io o se abituale
in più oggi io mi sono vestita evitare
ha detto bensì come mi vesto che tipo
sono sei tu quello che vuoi
guardate un po sì e metto la mia stessa
identica magliette mentre la via però ha
detto colore sapete perché
perché siamo un team unico
è un team speciale con lo stesso dolore
e poi chiedete ragazzi ciechi che c'ha
la volpe rossa questa prima io la
validità di questo colore tu mi hai
copiato ballando vedere altri challenge
sly considerate sicure che altre sale
zuppo diverse fare e mettetevi comodi
imprese tipo carne prima che cominci la
vita e che fortuna perché ci sono più
berilli adesso quindi sei fortunato
pronto prontissimo
vediamo allora sei pronto ecco libico
abbiamo può dire sì a farmene
ma dove vai 41 pensavo di marca
salafismo quindi non è montato in misura
però guarda un po cosa imprese per al 4
bit il pigmento great ancora
[Musica]
che strana coincidenza proprio come
ratti che vince la vita la croce inizia
bene possiamo passare questa volta
riguarda che non ricavi di quello
dobbiamo metterle assieme vediamo un
primo set up in the air che tocca a me
sono rimasti 123456 quindi spero di
riuscire a farli cadere tutti e sei
vediamo 3 2 1 2
vediamo volendo vediamo il verde
ovviamente non poteva che non capitare
cioè sono andata peggio di terra è
possibile invece di capitali numero uno
che non è verde molto polemica peccato
perché la colla hermes quella verde ma
si deve capitare
il numero 1 successivamente la tecnica
pc numero 1 e il numero 3 1 dal marito
paradiso tutto andiamo ora a mettere gli
ingredienti che vediamo come di vedi che
mettiamo il nostro amico di thriller the
moon
magari esse glossy però magari no
vediamo così affezionato che ammazza che
casino e tutti i comparti di color
bianco che dopo il disastro cosa c'è nel
iniziata proprio male andiamo a
mischiare il mozzo di troll che è brutta
guardo primo vero che mi dire balletto
da almeno non si vede tantissimo per ora
si è per ora vediamo un po come comune
diventerà con gli altri ingredienti
gruppo a carbone richiamo cervello
quarta partita grigia e belle grigia
pensi di riuscire a salvarla sì
sicuramente non ha colorato molto per
fortuna magari me lo fa per lato magari
già parlato
verremmo mescole che mi escono bel
colore
vedevo che si aprirà con ok tocca a me
speriamo di fare uno strike in spera di
prendere l'attivo di quei pinguini fare
10 vediamo questo vuol dire che io
inserisco carmine 1 e tokyo nel verde
no mi sembra gran bel niente
un colorante rosso vivo possono fare
michelin per devozione
ma l'ex di turno invece deve riuscire a
buttare un birillo storici o buttolo ti
becchi il verde spero non ti becchi
niente rimane grigio e di prodotto
allora devi riuscire a buttare quel
birillo lì penso di gestirsi si di euro
sono io a mettere il nostro rossa
speriamo che cancelli completamente il
modo di frolla che fortunata gli diamo
un po
[Musica]
che bello di tutto rosa il big one
certo bardolino li devono mi schiero
bene poi diventa pure rosa metallizzato
che bello ora devo solo riuscire a
prendere la schiuma di peppa pig così
diventa pure fra porta pero che se come
diventa è con verdolino ed rigetta e
allora mettiamo un po di verde al
braccio e colorato ha fatto bene comune
di fidenza partissimo e giriamo mediano
in ferro pastello verde
verde spagna no il verde pastello bene
dai ha recuperato un po meglio si
accorge sì mi piace vediamo chi li sa
fare
maledetto cosa speri che ti capiti
allora il blue dolls è emerso il gruppo
diventa del tutto grigio che giocoforza
la schiuma o lo schiaffo alle palline
quindi o numero 10 o numero 5 40 però di
farsi di prenderli tutti così
[Musica]
quindi capite rosa con perde un altro
quello di katy invece più orrore
il problema è che ora il bene però
marrone a vestirsi colore ma al
contrario va beh vediamo se riesco a
tirare lo zucchero
ok riuscì a buttare giù un solo periodo
per conquistare il verde non l'ha fatto
apposta
mi sarebbe capitato nessun ingrediente
15 è fortunata l'italia che quindi ma
questo turno assoluto matera è
l'ingrediente dai vecchi rosa vediamo
come diventa mar non abbiamo in rosa
questione metto poco però perché sono
veramente mia c'e troppo marrone non me
lo rovina dotto vediamo mischia di
vittoriana
di un tutto grigio non ci credo
l'indirizzo di partenza io la mentre dal
verdetto del grigio o forse grigio blu e
grigio blu e vediamo questo ti capiterà
luglio allora quarto e ultimo turno
quindi non cerca di essere fortunati
perché sarà il turno dei cd non so solo
che mi capito il blu questo punto così
almeno volere tipo di lavoro valutate le
nomine perché mi capiti l'attimo di peep
a ping ancora oppure l'adozione o le
palline sessioni a dire vediamo di cosa
che trovo che questa già scritto poi
prima molto più fortunato che può
capitare un numero molto più alto è vero
allora questa attenzione questo è il
tiro finale il tiro decisivo che
decideranno le sorti del tour slime
voglio il numero set
come posso fare numero7 blu vado no io
c'ero quasi numero 86 ma tributato
zufolo buttati giù se è qui nella con
barroso e tu sei per l'agguato non
dovere che cosa avrai
non mi dire il green altrimenti stimolo
prospettive certe sono molto più sfigata
io ha detto che lasciano 4
e allora il mio è un tiro impossibile
cioè io posso solo sperare di beccare
quei tre ma quello lì da solo e
impossibile che lo becco quindi qui
pronta ma il terremoto non li voglio
nemmeno fissa a va beh vediamo ritirare
no sono quasi i 3 15 fiscali va bene ok
vediamo come diventano grigi cosa c'è a
bari dove come rampa magari avessi avuto
mirror
no almeno cellette dalle paese che ha
liberato magari diventa molto grigio
non risucchiato che grigio concime e
grigio trasparente rosa è sparita
completamente risucchiato completamente
grigio blu ma è bellissimo abito blu
vedremo una volta attivo come eccoci qua
io la materia fishbowl che non c'entrano
un bel niente dai blues però nella
quella bianca no perché non si vedono
oggi loro adesso che la signora i dati
che vanno tutte bravo spiega ticino non
c'entrano proprio niente nel fatto che
mette un po di più come se l'elemento
veramente e lista
vedremo vedremo quante cadranno dunque
vivranno tutte ma non poteva capitarmi
ultimo di peppa pig passato dicendo che
noi siamo stati che poi per fare in un
non solo dire o fare strike price a meno
ma anche tu che eri bravo
[Applauso]
2 strike a 21 gradi comunque ora andiamo
ad attivarli e poi vi facciamo vedere
potrete votare
qual è il più bello con questo quindi so
mica se lo stupore secondo me uscirà un
bellissimo io se non avete avuto disco
sarebbe stato più bello
a metterlo adesso i prati 321 google e
sly il colore è bellissimo è un po
strano che sony bis volta dentro sembra
tipo una big babol con masticavano come
facile di cioccolato dentro mi piace un
sacco il colore fatto che sia un po
glossy è un po strano punto con le
fishbowl però non ci stanno troppo male
fit ev page ecco qua il mio big babol
con palline di cioccolato tra l'altro
non è carità niente una evitava abitare
la mia vita che amano sempre tutte le
niente perché non l'ha tirata troppo
fate super estendibile non si veda l'ora
fisco della risposta è non sai cosa dire
per titolo cascate
siamo un po di suoni momento ha detto mr
che bello per da sé che bello
wow quindi cosa ne pensate di questa
slide il colore che piace tantissimo e
vediamo ora quello di vitale castità non
mi aspettavo che esiste allora sembra
quasi sembra quasi celeste ma in realtà
è tipo e tipo grigetto grid grigio
grigio semestre oppure color cemento se
volete o peggio ma in realtà è uscito un
bel colore dal verde
sì perché c'erano i pigmenti grigi tipo
e quindi che carino e non è stupendo
c'è un'italia unita leggenda mercato lo
volevo viola sarebbe stato proprio
carino che suoni wow
i fondi così e così però il pochi invece
i pochi eletti ma si ribello non è
abbastanza elastico ma non troppo
bisogna stare attenti perché lo attivato
un pochettino non può intero un po
troppo andare amica questa bizzarra
questo di seta color ecco morgy
l'onomastica va però sono invidioso che
note caduta neanche una pallina è una
logica delle tute diventa viene lo
diventerà poi di un colore fantastico
adesso bello dove gigantesco muro eretto
dal mio colore che bello è diventato uno
slide marmorizzato della settima a testa
e compatto guarda comunque portate
quadri sondaggio per vinco io ho tipici
e vitale aiuta sempre cosa sia la
solitudine vincenzo vitale e cliccate
fatta per delirio per vedere i frutti di
video e buona visione
ciao